getting back into World of Warcraft has
kind of been like slipping on this old
comfortable jumper for me you know it's
well one and I know I probably shouldn't
wear it anymore but I do it's actually
been a while since I felt like I've been
this into the World of Warcraft's the
last time being when the first expansion
launched was which was the Burning
Crusade but with wallets of Draenor it's
like there's been a few reasons why I've
been like so into the game again the
story's characters actually characters
I'm interested in this time around you
know from the expansions after Burning
Crusade you know with office in the
mouth of the Lich King I didn't really
feel like I needed to know more about
him since I knew a lot of his origins
story already
and with Deathwing and Cataclysm you
know again a dragon something I wasn't
really interested in and with mists of
pandaria well I just didn't have a
reason to really get into that expansion
characters like thrall Jared Han
Grenache these characters I really got
to know them in Warcraft 3 and I really
liked them then and having them featured
in this ultimate timeline in Draenor is
kind of interesting to me and I really
like like we'd like to get to know them
better and Quest alongside them in
Draenor and when I spoke to the lead
game designer you know he mentioned that
this is kind of what they were going for
with Draenor
Borana is about actually going back and
visiting the birthplace of the orcs the
race to the center of a lot of the
Warcraft lore as well as the Jedi
players who are familiar with the
realtime strategy games that kind of
gave birth to all of this 15 or so years
ago may remember that you know Warcraft
2 beyond the Dark Portal will drown or
the Red Planet was what was beyond the
Dark Portal and actually looking back at
some of the instruction manuals from
from those games are part of what gave
rise to the idea to revisit the world
today Solar questing Indranil is pretty
epic it's great in that it feels like it
makes me feel like I'm part of something
really big and grant you know there's
big Wars and stuff going on and I have
an influence in what's happening in
Draenor these characters they they fight
beside you they address your character
you know you're transported around a lot
as part of the story and a lot of these
quests kind of finished with an
instanced area which have like a big
epic battle that you control and you
turn the tides in Draenor also
introduces this garrison feature which
is basically like the small plot of land
that you've given as a character and you
you build it up you put buildings into
it and you control it and it's sort of
like a base of operations and you know
it's it's not just a side quest thing
it's really integrated into what happens
in Draenor and I see these Garrison's as
a form of daily almost you know they
give people who are time for like me
something to do on the side it's easy
for me to log in and just you know send
my followers on missions it's really
convenient I can basically turn it into
a hub with almost everything I need
profession wise and it really minimizes
the number of times I need to go back to
the main cities the second thing is
managing Garrison's is very much a
single-player thing you do it on your
own you know you you go in and it's
instanced so no one else can be in your
garrison unless you invite other people
to come with you and you know it's this
thing that that's cool that that you can
share with other people that you've
built in journal want to offer ways for
players to branch out maybe it's not
something you're going to do right away
but maybe it'll be something that you do
a few months in once you've gotten your
characters to max level you're into a
rating cycle on off nights when your
bill is not rating what do you do
I think the garrison is a little bit
different because it's not strictly a
minigame it is also very much integrated
into the core storyline and experience
of leveling up and engaging in drown out
content there are aspects to it such as
collecting followers saying the
followers out on missions that have a
bit more of that feel you know it's a
way of introducing some offline
progression some other elements that we
haven't seen in World of Warcraft before
and that is designed to be a bit more
optional
it's all these changes that make world
of warcraft a different experience what
it was back in 2007 and that's not
necessarily a bad thing you know back in
the Burning Crusade days I was a student
who had a lot more time to spend on the
game
I guess it's fortunate for me now that
you know the solo questing experience is
easier it's less about grinding and it's
more about focusing on the story times
change